this video is sponsored by another Eden
another Eden is free-to-play JRPG
adventure for iOS and Android and before
I go any further this is written and
directed by Masato Kato who wrote the
likes of Chrono Trigger Xenogears heroes
of mana and many more yes I like a lot
of mobile games this is a super story
focused RPG with a lengthy 26th chapter
campaign visiting multiple timelines and
locations voice in both English and full
week yes it's a much more traditional
story driven JRPG and as a JRPG
enthusiast I already know all the ins
and outs look has warned me not to fight
this dude but I'm pretty confident I can
handle
[Music]
this must be the dark souls of
mobilegame get to choose between a big
variety of party members but I've also
got to mention the music because it was
composed by Yasunori Mitsuda and poor
econ studio who also works on Chrono
Trigger in Xenogears cuz this is by far
the best OSC I've heard for any mobile
game
[Music]
if this top class production sounds like
your cup of tea click the link in the
description to download it on iOS and
Android and with that said let's get on
with today's video anime in these don't
not that the ending of an anime no no
not not [ __ ] that the part that comes
at the end of an anime no not [ __ ]
that the final act of an anime in which
the events happening in the plot
characters in series come to a
conclusion aka the ending is an
important part of any anime it can be
the culmination of the journey that's
been taken it can give the entire series
a sense of resolution and closure and in
some cases can literally make or break
an anime but I feel in this age of
seasonal anime 3 episode rules dropping
shows harder than the asteroid that
killed the dinosaurs
something not discussed enough is anime
and all for [ __ ] ok a good friend of
mine once said the ending is Paramount
Pictures stay toasty but I feel like an
anime because of the ways made there are
different directions we as anime fans
see a lot from the conclusive to the
open-ended to the downright what the
[ __ ] so I wanted to just take this video
to just kind of discuss the different
types of endings we usually see my
perceptions of them as a whole and how
they fit into the anime culture in
general now I want to keep this a
general discussion about endings without
spoiling everything I'm talking about so
to help you avoid this on every section
I will be listing any shows in which I
either detail or show spoiler if your
plot points to do with the ending so if
you want to skip any sections the
timestamps of each section will be in
the description below so with that out
of the way first let's start with if
there's one easy way for a new anime to
grab my attention it's just by knowing
that it's an anime original series
firstly because this means we don't have
any source material meaning we don't get
those margaritas acting like 200 IQ
geniuses being like close but how will
you think's gonna happen
pour out of my only watches look at me
I'm so small because I know what's gonna
happen next Iggy then light novel
readers are there like
and secondly because it's not based on a
pre-existing IP it's likely that it will
have an ending that's conclusive or even
better it means the entire story from
beginning to end is already pre-planned
and I'm a original series are not common
occurrences but many shows order new
stick out to me because of this fact
Cowboy Bebop
erricka 7 Code Geass even in more recent
times with rhe creators in a place
further than the universe of course it
wasn't just the ending that made these
show stand out but it did help a lot
something like zankyou no terror despite
a lot of the problems I had with it
stick with me clearly because it felt
like a complete story that was planned
out with an ending I've really enjoyed
and like holy [ __ ] re craters did this
revolutionary thing in anime called an
epilogue where the entire last episode
was no action no plot it was just
dedicated to tying up loose ends and
seeing more characters who opted to
after the story was concluded to leave
the viewer with a sense of closure
what guff [ __ ] but of course just
because something is anime original
doesn't mean it's guaranteed to have a
good ending in fact there used to be
this thing called Gainax endings where
certain shows coincidentally produced by
studio Gainax
would get endings that made no sense or
server sequel hooks to sequels that were
never made
fortunately Gainax endings nowadays
seems to have died with the decline of
the studio only to find themselves East
Lake Ida - trigger for its own light
novel adaptation of that time I got
reincarnated as darling in the Franks
but even some anime that have had a
conclusive enough endings have had a
reoccurring issue because if it gets
enough success in popularity there's
always a chance that the creators felt
it was appropriate to revive it and have
another go
there are little things that are sacred
in anime these days and one of them
certainly isn't the legacy of a popular
franchise it doesn't matter how good or
how conclusive and complete your series
can be when it's over there's always
gonna be a way to retcon or a spool or
literally resurrect anew narrative to
milk a few more dollars out of beloved
franchises just in time to give me my
jib boon rolls on the rare occasion you
get something like die buster adding a
new story in the same world years after
gun buster but there are numerous
examples of sequels coming in that not
only result in a vastly inferior ending
to the original series but even going as
far as completely [ __ ] up and ruining
the established canon
we went from darker than black season 1
Chinese electric Batman to darker than
black season 2 alcoholic dad simulator
madoka rebellion was a sequel movie that
people had opinions about and then
there's a record seven AO now if a o is
viewed as a standalone series it would
be fine just a fairly forgettable
average show but as a sequel it's a
[ __ ] travesty introducing plot
elements that completely broke
characters and themes from the original
going as fliers to confirm that the
[ __ ] spin-off reboot movie will
somehow canon in some bizarre multiverse
time travel [ __ ] our Suri's and just in
general trampling all over the world and
themes of the original series there's a
discussion to be had on whether the
existence of these sequels have ruined
the value of the original ending but
there are also a few shows that have had
pretty decent endings in the sense that
they concluded everything they needed to
well they still left room for a sequel
which were eventually made that really
didn't live up to the original
the first Psychopaths had some truly
interesting and brilliant ideas that
were explored and has yet to be
replicated nothing from steins gate
either from its sequel movies or zero
came close to capturing the original
spirit and the only thing I thought the
new foody Coody brought to the table was
a few new great tracks from the pillows
I think my problem with all these is
that they are examples where sequel
definitely wasn't needed or originally
planned but they made one anyway it's
not like a mob psycho season two's of
today where the storyline didn't end and
the sequel continues to add and enhance
the plots for the original series have
said everything it wants to and put a
full-stop in it making it hard for any
sequel to capture that same magic even
if in some cases it had left space for
further ideas to be explored however to
go in the complete opposite direction
you sometimes get anime that choose to
give itself a conclusive ending even if
the
story actually continues kind of loss
art nowadays our anime that follow the
source material up to a point on each
diverge from its giving an ending that's
more conclusive either because the
source material they are adapting from
misty would complete or far too long to
cover in the episode counts they are
given now when I say some lost art I
mean it kind of dug its own grave set
itself from fire and jumped in head
first Soul Eater Claymore Helsing blue
exorcist Gant a karma girl killed while
all of these shows had conclusive
endings that stopped to the point before
the manga had instead of achieving their
purpose of ending the series in a
satisfying way it just made fans want to
end themselves the problem with anime
original endings is that when an anime
tries to go a different direction in
order to give an ending that's more
conclusive you miss out on the proper
build-up and foreshadowing to make this
happen
this is made even more confusing when
you get sequel seasons that continue to
follow the manga for an anime that's
already been given a conclusion in most
cases you can just pretend the final
anime only arca didn't happen and just
continue business as usual but
occasionally you get something like
Tokyo ghoul roots a the completely anime
only sequel to Tokyo ghoul aka Tokyo
ghoul season 2 not to be confused with
Tokyo ghoul re season 2 which is the
second season - Tokyo ghoul read the
sequel season 2 Tokyo ghoul because
Tokyo ghoul roots egg aka season 2
doesn't follow the manga so that makes
Sookie oh cool 3 the Canon second season
of Tokyo ghoul except Tokyo ghoul re aka
Callen 2nd season doesn't immediately
continue the events of Tokyo ghoul
season 1 I mean why the [ __ ] with it
right so instead they continues one from
Tokyo ghoul manga obviously which was
never fully adapted into an anime which
makes it really easy to follow so if
you're an anime only watcher it's
actually pretty simple
all you need to do is watch Tokyo ghoul
then read the Tokyo ghoul manga than
watch the Tokyo ghoul live-action then
comes a Tokyo ghoul musical within Tokyo
ghoul grant order for the Nintendo DS
and then after you've done all that
you're finally ready to play Kingdom
Hearts 3 - my recollection the only
anime original ending that has been
positively received has been the
original format of alchemist and what
made this possible was the fact that
since the anime started diverging by the
halfway point it was able to carve out
its own narrative and tackle things in a
different way giving much more adequate
time to set up its ending and for his
time people were satisfied considering
the original manga was still ongoing
having said that though nowadays I get
the sense that this ending is looked
down upon because we now have
Brotherhood which remakes the entire
series to give an ending the majority
seem to agree was much better than what
we originally got and this is why I feel
you just don't see this kind of ending
nowadays if you diverge from the source
material is very hard to make something
satisfactory even if you make it
conclusive and fans seemingly would much
rather be left hanging than given a
conclusion that absolutely sucks dick
and that leads us to our next section in
the technical term we know as I must be
showing my age that's not what the cool
kids are saying these days that's better
as we know every story has a beginning a
middle and an end
except in anime where we get a beginning
half a middle and a season 3 that's
never gonna come this is a very common
occurrence in anime we see an
interesting set up to a story or world a
major arc or two happens and just as you
feel you've just about scratched the
surface of what it has to offer its ends
and you never hear from it again if
you're an anime fan you've probably
experienced this a lot especially in the
shorts hard-hitting seasonal anime
culture as they can sometimes feel like
certain anime were made as a glorified
advert for the source material see when
it comes to people who read source
material like manga there are two types
of manga readers the brain rare heroic
Souls who throw themselves into the
expansive world of manga working
tirelessly to find that next hidden gem
within the ocean of unknown titles and
then there's everyone else who saw an
airing and main couldn't wait to find
out what happens next back in the day
there were some pretty infamous and
things for doing this and by infamous I
mean it was like the animators ran out
of paper to draw on and we're like yeah
let's just cut two credits and hope
nobody cares err yeah Batum the original
Hunter hunter High School of the Dead
these just ended right in the middle of
a story arc with all number of story
threads up in the air before just
stopping dead no conclusion no promise
of another season just cut two credits
and then you had the original berserk
which didn't just stop in the middle of
a story arc but right in the middle of
the most shocking scarring turn of
events that literally destroyed a man
leaving him bleeding tears of blood
screaming and anger in a state of shock
betrayal aghast at the events that just
unfolded and I was just me I don't even
know how guts
back then fans would have sold their
soul to see what happens next and little
did we know that twenty years later we'd
get our wish yeah we got our wish right
we have no rights we got our [ __ ] wit
who made a deal with the [ __ ] the
helots to make this wish come true
nowadays what I will say is that seasons
at least are more carefully planned out
so audiences get some kind of closure in
the arts that they tackle but still if
you've been an anime fan for a while I'm
sure you've gotten used to the feeling
of waiting for a season two or three
that's may or may not ever come whether
that be our easy road holy [ __ ] [ __ ]
are you serious no game no life spice
and wolf the devil was a part-timer all
countless other shows if you're lucky
you may get another season or I guess
the hot new thing nowadays is sequel
movies oh look at that sexy boy walking
down the red carpet but even then will
it ever even come close to completion
not likely part of the life cycle within
the anime and manga culture is that we
get an anime adaptation when you have a
hot title and that rarely happens after
a title has already ended on the rare
occasion you get something like devil
man crybaby where the anime is adapting
an old title that's finished but more
often than not you find yourself
finishing the animes and when you catch
up to the mongrel light novel the story
is still at least a few years away from
completion one thing above and hate
about the medium of anime is just how
many new shows with massive variety we
constantly get but the downside of that
is as an anime fan you get used to being
introduced to stories characters and
worlds which you know you're never gonna
see the ending of and honestly I think
that's kind of a shame because to me
even though I don't think the ending is
always the most important factor a lot
of the anime they have stuck in my mind
years after they have finished are the
ones that end
[Music]
now you may be sitting there wondering
why I cared enough about anime endings
that I would want to make a whole video
on it and that's because I just wanted
to express how much I value a great
ending well I don't think every series
needs a fantastic ending or even a
proper ending for it to be a fantastic
series the ones that do have one I never
forget my favorite anime ending of all
time still is Code Geass as original
ending now over a decade later when I
think back to Code Geass with the second
season in mind especially I don't
remember the complete mess it was at
times the complete flip-flopping of
characters that suited whatever the plot
needed or whoever the [ __ ] this little
[ __ ] was does anyone remember the cat
episode does anyone remember the pizza
episode I remember season 2 episode 25
breathe I remember the lucious sacrifice
I remember the trumpets of madder Sky
blaring as they explained the zeroes
Requiem jaws wide open
goosebumps galore as I realized holy
[ __ ]
everything had a point everything was
leading up to this one moment and
feeling a sense of all jubilation
sadness and emptiness all at once as the
credits started rolling and that is the
power of a great ending
it's that bittersweet void that tells
you that the journey is over as much as
you love the path you took to get here
and never wanted it to end the fact that
it did end makes it even more special
and you wouldn't have it any other way
because yes sometimes it's about the
journey not the destination but when you
have a breathtaking destination it can
give even more meaning to that journey
and make that entire voyage you took
that much more extraordinary nowadays so
much focus is given to how to begin a
story with so many anime competing for
your attention every season it's all
about how to make the highest impact as
fast as possible how to immediately
stand out from the crowd but to me
it's the ending that sticks with you
there have been plenty of anime with
great beginnings that slowly fizzle out
and get forgotten but I have never
forgotten an anime with a great ending
it wraps up everything the story was
trying to say allows me to truly reflect
on the anime as a whole and kind of make
peace with the fact that it is complete
because if you end your anime right it
can be a moment you'll never forget hey
guys hope you enjoyed that video again I
just wanted to give a quick thanks to
another
edan for making this video possible if
any of what I said has interested you
then please check them out in the link
below just a quick note it's not
available officially on app stores in
Europe at the moment but they are
looking for a full European release soon
and with that said thank you very much
to Ella for Robert Hahn Borg Basel now
Ken and everyone else on my patreon for
supporting me this month also know a lot
of you have been asking but I will be
doing another seasonal chart anime
stream when I go through all the anime
next season as can be next week on
Wednesday the 3rd of April at 3 p.m.
Eastern Daylight Time here on YouTube I
wanted to do on a weekend but
unfortunately I am not free for any of
the weekends coming up and I wanted to
experiment with doing a stream on
YouTube as last time yours on my twitch
and a lot of people weren't even aware
that I had a twitch so yeah anyway
that's it from me though I've been
gigging and I'll see you all next time